hi I'm Nana ponds and I'm doing the
wired autocomplete interview whoo-hoo
lily pond so who is lily ponds a single
child who was born and raised in
Venezuela and came to the United States
I make videos since I was 16 and I love
Shakira crocodiles and eating a lot of
pasta who is Lily pons best friend Tuan
Tuan is my best friend and my cousins
are my best friends who did it who did
it little pawns um it could mean a lot
of things oh who did it it's one of my
my youtube videos it's about a food
fight who did it like who was the one
that initiated it pretty sure I did it
who who run the world Lily pons who run
the world then upon sits a beat one
interview that I did which was called to
round the world
I did it with julissa and Hannah then
who is Lele pons related to um I think
people who searches are trying to figure
out if I'm related to this one
Latin singer called Cheyenne which I am
he Cheyenne is married to the sister of
my mom so we're not really related blood
but he is my god
father and my uncle did Lily pons go to
medical school yeah I went to like pick
up a friend there does little Ponce
speak Spanish no lo creo no no say no
pienso no no yes I speak Spanish I speak
three languages actually speak Spanish
Italian and a little bit of English
Spanish is my first language Italian is
my second and English is my third so see
my opinion when did lily ponds start
buying I started buying when I was 16
years old and I was thinking I was the
only Viner who was doing stuff in school
how is lily ponds related to China and I
told you
my mom's sister is married to him so not
by blood but because he loves my my aunt
can lily ponds sing I'm trying
I took opera for four years when I was
like 10 to 14 and then I started vine
and I stopped completely and then right
now I did a song called solo solo kara
and decent which they've done really
good solo so has is is triple platinum
so I'm really excited I'm really happy
about that so yes yes
Oh what lily ponds what is Lele pons
real name my real name is not elephant's
it's a little complicated so it's
Eleonora it's not Eleanor it's a Leo
Norah yo'ii oh and oh our a because my
mom wanted to be complicated but whose
baby are you gonna call and you know
come here no so they shortened it out to
just Lily and then what is lily ponds
famous for I think I am famous for vine
I started on vine and then YouTube and
God knows what else
sometimes I'm famous for doing the
Scooby Doo Papa video then other people
think I'm famous for like The Voice
Mexico that I did I mean I don't know a
couple of things I mean I don't even
know what I'm famous for it just
happened what country is Lily from I am
from Venezuela Caracas and then I was
raised in when I showed up but in
terrain a place called terrain but I see
metro and part of Kerry WA I was like
between those places what college did
Lily pons go to I didn't go to any
college and not go to college I'm dumb I
wanted to go to New World
I wanted to go to Berkeley in Boston but
I did not go to college I went straight
to LA from there because I started vines
when I was 16 years old and then when I
was 18 I decided to actually pursue the
career of fine I went to buy an academy
what is let upon's
favorite food pasta tortellini from my
grandma the pasta the peaks everything
that has to do with tallying food is
little pots so is little ponds
Camilla caballos sister yes in the
Havana music video
was her sister but not in real life I
don't but I wish is that it pawns me get
no I can't I love I love I love meat I'm
sorry I can't be vegan I eat everything
I wish I was is Lily pons in Baywatch no
only in like my friend Hannah's YouTube
video but not in the Baywatch Baywatch
right
is that a consonant Juan related while I
kissed him in videos I kiss him in video
so no he'll know we're not related but
we're best friends and we have never
really liked each other never been in
relationships Oh No wherever later we're
best friends
then it Potts where is everyone's house
my house is in Miami right now I have a
house in Miami with my dad and then I
live here so it's in Hollywood with my
mom is Lily pons real now where does
Lily pons work I work in LA it was shot
studios and what is later posted middle
name
nothing I wish I had animator name
whatever my name it or name is Sophia
how how lily ponds so how is little
ponds I'm good
I'm great lonely and single how many
subscribers does lily ponds have I have
15 million subscribers on YouTube how do
you do the eye thing lily ponds that
well I can do it Hana can but I can't do
in mine the eye thing is a VFX so it's
an effect that my friend does I can't do
it I can't but Hannah does how how old
is leather pants today I am 23 years old
born on June 25 1996 how to be like Lily
pons how can you be me you have to love
Spanish music love Italian food be
outgoing a stuntwoman
single all the time and be yourself to
be honestly the more spontaneous you are
that's how you
coming be spontaneous unique and crazy
very very crazy and don't be afraid to
speak your mind wear leather pants where
is Hans parents from my mom is from
Venezuela born in Venezuela my dad it
was also born from in Venezuela my mom's
family is from Italy though and my dad's
family is from Spain where is the
depands right now I live in LA los
angeles-hollywood where do little ponds
live in LA we're doing little ponds go
to high school I went to high school in
Miami Country Day in Miami
what little ponds what is little ponds
height I am five seven what is the upon
favorite color red red what is a little
ponds job I can just say I'm an
entertainer I entertain and a creator
what does lily ponds mean I don't know
but someone said that it means catfish
in a language I don't know which one but
it doesn't mean anything it just means
what you're looking at right here thank
you so much wired for having me this was
a lot of fun